hablamos de las heridas causadas por la
operación orión 20 años después el mayor
intervención militar urbana en Colombia
en la comuna 13 de Medellín las mujeres
se unen para exigir la verdad y los
jóvenes responden con arte a la
violencia saludamos a Juana Esteban
Jaramillo les coordinador y relator
principal del informe el modelo
paramilitar de Medellín de la dirección
de acuerdos de la verdad del Centro
Nacional de memoria histórica Juan
Esteban Gracias por estar con nosotros
en este espacio de Francis 24 llamado
directo América vamos a dar un contexto
internacional a nuestra audiencia un
resumen de lo que pasó entre 13 y 16 y
17 de octubre del año 2012 en la comuna
13 de Medellín
claro Buenos días y muchas gracias por
invitación en primer lugar pues señalar
que esta fue una operación
militar que se inscribía dentro de toda
una serie de acciones que ya se venían
desarrollando en la ciudad de Medellín
desde el año 2002 operaciones como la
operación otoño contra fuego
Horizonte antorcha Mariscal y otras que
tenían como propósito Pues por un lado
garantizar el control de este territorio
por parte de las estructuras
paramilitares pero a la vez derrotar
Pues digamos que el enemigo insurgente y
miliciano que se situaba en estos
lugares Entonces digamos que se inscribe
dentro de dentro de una acción de toma
del poder por parte de estructuras para
militares que empiezan a tener presencia
en la ciudad de Medellín y la sufracción
del valle de aburrada desde mediados de
los años 90 una segunda generación
paramilitar que va a tener una extensión
en el territorio de Medellín hasta el
año 2006 cuando se desmoviliza una de
las víctimas estructuras paramilitares
esta segunda generación que fue el
bloqueo desde Granada Entonces digamos
que esta operación orión se marca
Precisamente en lo que fue la toma
paramilitar por parte esa estructura que
contó con todo el apoyo pues obviamente
de sectores de la fuerza pública y de
sectores políticos de la ciudad y la
región 20 años después Juan Esteban Cómo
están las cosas como siguen las heridas
en la sociedad
Pues digamos que el gran problema que se
presenta con esta operación con con los
resultados de esta operación es que
sigue
primando la impunidad a pesar de que se
han logrado esclarecer algunos asuntos y
aspectos sobre las relaciones que se
tejieron entre actores institucionales y
y los paramilitares para esta operación
el papel de la justicia en el
esclarecimiento de este tipo de hechos
ha sido precario el papel de la fiscalía
por ejemplo en lo que ha sido el
juzgamiento de los paramilitares de
distancias de justicia y paz ha sido
bastante mediocre como lo han señalado
incluso los mismos magistrados del
tribunal de justicia y paz de las
diferentes sentencias que han preferido
contra las estructuras paramilitares
los nexos que existen y que existieron
en su momento con miembros de la fuerza
pública todavía no han sido
suficientemente esclarecidos y pues
bueno en medio del informe que nosotros
elaboramos
que está en ese momento en proceso de
edición pues lo digamos podemos
determinar a partir de la entrevista y
relatos con los diferentes
participantes del mecanismo de lo
judicial de contribución a la verdad que
desarrolló el que desarrolló el centro
de memoria en donde participaban Pues
desmovilizados de esta estructura
logramos determinar que en efecto pues
varios de sus testimonios dan cuenta de
cómo fue una incursión conjunta entre
miembros de la fuerza pública y que no
fue solamente esta incursión sino todas
las demás que los antecedieron y que no
solo fue la comuna 13 sino en las
diferentes zonas de la ciudad de
Medellín en la zona norte nororiental
noroccidental centro Oriente y centro
occidente principalmente fueron las
zonas donde se concentró este el
accionar de esta estructuras
paramilitares y contaron además de del
apoyo de la fuerza pública mediante
estas operaciones militares también con
otro tipo de apoyos que pasaban desde la
desde la mera tolerancia de la presencia
de los paramilitares de una presencia
abierta en la cual no había ningún tipo
de inter hasta articulación en lo que
tenía que ver con acciones de control
social y grado desvelaciones a los
derechos humanos
en los diferentes lugares donde hicieron
presencia al punto que incluso él pues
casos también de lo que se ha denominado
en Colombia como falsos positivos
ejecuciones extrajudiciales que fueron
desarrolladas en conjunto pues
obviamente entre paramilitares y
miembros de la fuerza pública Qué ha
pasado con los desaparecidos han tenido
respuestas digamos donde se pueden
encontrar quienes serían estos estos
desaparecidos también en Juan Esteban
ha existido en la ciudad desde desde la
operación orión un movimiento de
víctimas buscando precisamente que se
puedan recuperar los cuerpos de las
personas desaparecidas en la actualidad
hay varios procesos abiertos en sobre
este asunto Desafortunadamente la
negligencia que marcó
las acciones iniciales de los gobiernos
municipal departamental incluso nacional
en su momento para salvaguardar los
sitios en donde donde Donde se supone
que están las personas que fueron
desaparecidas fueron fueron bastante
tardías esto ha generado digamos que
situaciones bastante complejas para
poder dar con con los cuerpos de las
personas dadas por desaparecida pero
Digamos que ya contrastando los relatos
que nosotros logramos recoger pues
Confirmamos buena parte de lo que han
sido las denuncias de las organizaciones
de víctimas y diferentes organizaciones
sociales en el sentido de que pues
varios de Los paramilitares que
participaron en nativos militares
señalan que en efecto en las cumbreras y
en varias zonas aledañas a la misma
fueron arrojados varios de los cuerpos
van quedando desaparecidos en Perdón que
iban quedando muertos en medio de la
confrontación Armada Juan Esteban de
cuánto desaparecidos y muertos estamos
hablando
Pues bueno habría que en este momento no
tengo la cifra exacta pero si digamos
que lo que ha venido haciendo la gente
en este momento y y diferentes
instancias dado cuenta precisamente de
un número elevado de víctimas por
desaparecidas Tenemos un gran problema y
es que Pues precisamente por por la
negligencia que hubo en las
investigaciones iniciales no tenemos una
cifra exacta de Cuántas son las personas
das por desaparecidas tienen Esperanza
ustedes en la justicia especial para la
paz en Colombia
las Eva ha hecho una labor muy
importante en lo que tiene que ver con
la protección de sitios de inhumación
viene haciendo la labor importante lo
que tiene que ver con el acopio de
testimonios y creemos que la gente y la
labor también que ha venido haciendo la
unidad de búsqueda de personas por
desaparecidas pueden tener unos
resultados importantes para el
esclarecimiento de estos de estos hechos
Bueno estaban rápidamente Cómo hacen
para combinar el arte para luchar contra
la violencia no Y también por la memoria
de lo que pasó para que no vuelva a
ocurrir algo así Pues digamos que el
arte ha sido la principal estrategia de
resistencia y de sobrevivencia que han
tenido los diferentes
colectivos que se han situado estos
territorios que han construido estos
territorios de que los han conformado y
que ha servido para precisamente
mantener en pie a comunidades enteras en
estos barrios en medio de la guerra
Entonces digamos que el arte ha sido una
forma de encontrar y darle
la computación Pero además de
transformar esa realidades Y pues lo
último que quería frente a ese paso
pregunta es que de no haber sido por
todos estos colectivos de arte la
situación en en y todos los colectivos
de resistencia a la situación hubiera
sido mucho peor es gracias a ellos sino
tanto las acciones institucional que se
ha logrado mantener una civilidad en
esta ciudad